we are with a Vlad Giza Vlad first of
all tell us a bit about yourself I know
you're a pretty decent player as well
um okay this is on a relative scale
depends how you define decent I'm a 2000
rated ELO player I love the game very
much and I'm very happy to be here
amongst the true professionals but
you're also a coach as well do you have
any players we know that there's some
youth competitions going on around here
do you have any players uh here any
students so not at the moment actually
I've been specializing in coaching a
subset of adult improvers as they like
to call themselves on Twitter using the
hashtag justpunks so most of my students
are adult improvers and right now I'm
trying to scale down a bit on the number
of students because I just started a new
job you've been here since the beginning
I remember I saw you in the first
edition uh of the grandchester held here
in Bucharest how do you feel uh like
this has progressed in the four years
that we've been holding this tournament
here in Bucharest well actually that's a
very good question I don't remember my
first time when I was visiting the grand
chess tour but I have to say that I
really loved last year's Edition it was
my favorite of course we're hoping that
this year's Edition is going to surpass
that but uh the one reason why I really
loved last year is because I got to hang
out with Levon aronian and his wife we
just had a great time and I really
missed them yeah but this year we have
the world champion for the first time in
Romania we didn't have Magnus previously
in the previous years but now we have
ding Loren we also have the Challenger
they just battled it all out in a world
championship match how do you feel how
do you sense their energy right now well
I'm not surprised to hear to see that
Ding made a draw in the first round and
it looks like Jan's position despite
having a very you know like active King
on D4 it looks like black might have
some chances to hold but then again
don't rely too much on my evaluation
please trust stockfish more Vlad thank
you very much for joining us so much
this weekend
[Music]